[Music]
right away when I wake up in the morning
I'm like okay what else did am I gonna
take off today
I believe that I'm gonna find the man of
my dream on this beautiful island wow
you are really high thank you I will
have a cell phone I won't have emails
what the hell am i doing know what I am
making connections with multiple men do
you feel like you're gonna find love
here
[Music]
you're a geezer pleaser huh what the
hell did I get myself into I feel like
I'm dreaming you never know what can
happen daily naked that's what we called
mangina and then you go like that that's
a fruit basket just get that much more
uncomfortable than this I'd say we just
need to find sanity my best date so far
has been a few last night I had the
craziest sex dream about you I've never
tried so hard in my life
because I am head over heels for you
you're just making me all giggly
don't lie to me a man is gonna tell you
what they want you to hear you call me a
lot don't be taking it all in
I never thought it'd be so difficult to
juggle this many naked women yep no
horror shows everything you're naked if
it was easy then wouldn't be why should
I just never ever want to lose our
relationship I don't want to have any
respect
it's an all new season of dating naked
premieres Wednesday June 29th at 9:00
only on vh1
[Music]